Jason Locke and flora how are you Jason
obviously Brockman's got the inside
track right with Argentina yeah I mean
how do you not root for Messi if you
truly appreciate greatness and we just
saw Ovechkin shed this label of he's not
a winner as teams don't get it done in
the clocks you can't win on the biggest
the big stages and I'm not seeing
American guys so part of me is kind of
like well I don't know if Messi never
wins one then maybe Diego remembered as
finally as it should be for his on-field
exploits but he's such a great player I
would love to see him dominate this
tournament and and you know to get his
due and and you know have all those
knocks erased and put him up there with
Maradona and Pele and price that said be
your best guess what do you think
hoist the cup in July maybe this is
Argentinian yeah I don't love their
backline it could be they may have to
score score 5 to win some of these
matches but you know that's not out of
the realm of possibility you can never
bet against Germany especially in a
tournament that the proximities there
Germany playing in Europe there's always
a safe bet and I would love to see an
African nation the Nigeria somebody
really have have a great run and maybe
make it to semi-finals or something like
that well I mean obviously the u.s. is
not in this competition Jason what the
US is any competition for the 2026 World
Cup with a joint bid with Mexico and
Canada interestingly enough with what's
going on in the world against Morocco
what are the tea leaves what are the tea
leaves as you're reading it right now
when that announcement gets made in
Russia tomorrow honey it's our that the
president has time to maybe send out a
tweet and and wreck all that right we
hate Canada now unbelievable South Park
come to life when Santa I mean
look every rational part of my seidman
being says it has to happen but every
rational part of my firemen being with a
said in 86 when they played it in Mexico
when the revolutions were taking place
in Colombia I would have thought that it
was going to the US then and every
rational part of my fiber and beam would
have said there's no way that Qatar with
fake clouds in a bubble that doesn't
exist and Russia given what everything
that's happened there we could
we're going to get a 20-minute before
the US but they got you know Fox out of
both of those cycles so until the vote
goes down and everything's official I
wouldn't you know I wouldn't bet against
it but I think they're really only
against Morocco and the way the bids
were written and the initial I guess
sort of pedigree that they attach to the
page the the the US the North American
bid was so far advanced from Morocco but
I guess there's still times for tweets
and blogs and all that great I hope I
hope we get it I mean it would really I
mean especially now with the state of
soccer in this country I think it would
be huge to have that that carrot dangled
out there and to maybe really kick some
people in the backside and motivate them
to make up for lost time and try to make
the most of that tournament all right
let's talk about the domestic football
seen the the pigskin the Duke in the
National Football League with NFL
insider from CBS sports Jason Locke and
flora Terrell Awad didn't show up today
and John Robinson of the Titans just
sent out a release saying that they've
been trying to work on his contract or
at least have a conversation with him
over the last five six weeks is this
been bubbling or and just came to the
surface here Jason yeah it wasn't one
that I was paying too much attention to
but I mean honestly for any of these
guys
anybody who has outperformed their
contract and and wants to skip and a
mini camp and make the calculated gamble
that don't get that 85k back on the back
end but that's a good way to sort of
rattle some change and get some people's
attention and and and I mean I get that
Robinson understands they want to get
something done but I'm sure that he's
sitting there looking at Nate's older
saying well that guy 16 what am i I mean
what where should I be a key you know 17
20 I mean I don't know this offseason is
going to create a lot of issues for a
lot of fun offices with what happened
with cousins and what happened with
Larkin and even at the lower scale where
Dante Moncrief walks in a building with
10 million in his pocket and a chance to
make 2 million more if he's just who
he's always been which is like I don't
know a three and a half
a full receiver if he just shows up for
work more times or not I I don't know
rich I mean David Johnson not surprised
at all well Thomas not surprised at all
saw those coming and I guess you know
had I looked at luan situation more I
woulda said yeah I get it there too
the market moved really everywhere other
than safety and running back and any
that McKinnon contract to a certain
degree I think how to get some people
attention at running back it you know
things things went in an exponential
fashion and the caps continuing to go up
and who knows what that new CPA is gonna
look like down the road so I get it yeah
well with Julio Jones Odell Beckham and
levy on bail which which God do you
think is most likely to get a new
contract before the season begins Jason
I think let me I'm fell to the bottom of
that list the other two I don't see how
the Giants can play chicken without Dell
just because he's putting on the brave
face now or you know extending olive
branches and and smiling and saying and
doing all the right things and it's
wanting to do that now if he's still set
to make eight million dollars come
August and September I don't think we're
going to see a whole lot of Odell and
the giant I think have to realize that I
would put him at the top of us which I
guess means Julio goes in the middle I
don't I don't know that Julio's going to
get like Odell Beckham that's a complete
that's a new contract you don't I mean
that's at least two full new years and
maybe three added on to what he's
supposed to make this year however they
want to skin that cat I think we'll
maybe more of us sweeten the pot add
some incentive give him you know maybe
throw a few million more than now but I
don't think he's in this quite the same
boat those other two are in certainly
not Odell who's a storm track I know do
be talking 20 million for him is that
we're talking on her you know how you
get around that I don't know how you get
around that because it's there for him
and he knows that and so he's sitting
there with his agent and they're looking
at the the landscape and they're saying
standing walking maybe one year in Sammy
Watkins career he was even the best most
productive receiver on his own team much
less believe and he gets you know forty
five million guaranteed and keep that
seventeen how am I
not a 20 I mean it's it's just III
because 32 team League you're not going
to come in if he's on the open market
there isn't one that would do it and it
only takes one and frankly I think
there's more than one I mean Landry I
mean if nice player and everyday 16
million for a SWAT guy leverages nine
yards but that's not me didn't yet know
much well yeah I think I say 20 years of
legit number a few more minutes left
with Jason Locke and for awhile we've
had this conversation video of a white
whale was just posted correct on Twitter
Chris Brockman correct by the
indianapolis cold and what does that
video say Andrew Luck throwing a
football cat that Jason while we're
chatting maybe that's what they were
going to say that was for us to talk
yeah I guess so yeah look it's a long
road to hoe here and that's awesome and
it obviously has to start somewhere and
it starts with with and throwing down
you know throwing around the Duke I'm
assuming I'm not looking at my Twitter
right now I'm assuming he's throwing a
regulation football I don't know if it's
it does not it does not look like a nerf
or a peewee okay oh that does look like
the genuine article no no no what I mean
it is a nice spiral he's moving to stand
around oh yeah
you know obviously the expectations for
any football fan anybody who appreciates
the game is is that he gets back playing
and then can get back to where he left
off before he kind of started becoming
damaged goods but it is a long process
and last year unfortunately didn't get
very far down it right anybody never I
don't we never got to publish throw in
consecutive games maybe sorry
consecutive days much less anybody
talking about a game you know much less
than even throwing the full route tree
so they've got to continue to take baby
steps as they will but you hope with
that additional treatment and the
additional time off and healing that
it's smooth sailing here but it's going
to be a long checklist with a lot of
sort of baby steps along the way and and
hopefully there's no swelling
inflammation or anything that that you
know sets him off the long or the long
pass but even right now I mean it's
almost a little June you know I mean no
no it's are going to be here before you
know it
and even this I would I would have to
say it's suboptimal you would have loved
for this
have been in March that said it is what
it is as the coaches say and at least
that's it's it's something rather than
nothing last one for you Josh Allen
working with the ones a little bit in
the first day of this mini camp many
will be back to the threes according to
the bills
yeah handicap for me the week one rookie
class do you think that we're gonna see
out there any of them play week going
right
that would be an upset Jason dowdy a
rarity to I think I would bet against it
barring injury I would bet against it I
saw the bills I'll be it I just
parachuted in for a day last week and
Josh Allen was with the threes and you
see the speed at the legs and the arm
talent but there was a lot of balls on
the ground a lot of balls thrown too low
and you know I think don't they'll take
their time with him a little bit because
they know what they turn it over to him
there's there's really no going back
just not going to be a yo-yo I think he
plays in the first half of the season I
think you may play could be like
travesty well he plays in October I
don't know that he plays week one ha I
would think he'd have the best odds of
doing that and now Bradford's on could
fall off in August
where's knee or whatever is the bionic
man he's all together with super glue
and duct tape so you know maybe that's
rosin but if you put a gun to my head
right now I I think I would I would
certainly bet the under and I don't know
that any of them play we've won I think
start week one I don't want you to I
think could be Lamar Jack's was the
first one on the field because down
distance situation puts him on in a goal
line situation and nobody else starts
that would be I guess somewhat ironic
but I wanna be stunned if he actually
good from the field first well he's got
to get on the field Jason I mean we've
heard this conversation he hurt 480
yards a yards and points challenged
offense that lacked dynamism in so many
different ways last year he has to get
on the field and the question is is if
he's the quarterback or a quarterback
how do they square the circle by putting
him behind Flacco at all or splitting
Flacco out wide I mean III think look
Flacco will come off the field and this
guy will go in and he will run are PIOs
and you will run you know it's not going
to be a completely different
often during my daughter it's not going
to be gimmicks and gadgets he's gonna
run stuff that Alex look for in last
year and and true Bastille and last year
and that and that Marty morning when had
Michael Vick doing you know seven eight
years ago I whatever it was I would look
at it in those terms and he's coming in
to be the quarterback the Flacco's going
to stay on the sidelines fourth D plays
and when you average five point seven
yards per attempt which will probably be
some yards below with Lamar Jackson
averages per carry this year then fact
what happened Jason depreciate the time
enjoy the World Cup and we'll chat down
the line throughout the summer you got a
Jason Lockett floor at Jason locking for
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience